new research shows that those who like
to stay awake late at night are less
likely to be healthy not only that night
owls have a 10 higher risk of death than
those who go to bed at a good time are
you an early riser or are you a night
owl
i am a lifelong insomniac and i no
longer have something in part due to
having a consistent nightly ritual
why is an evening routine even important
because when all of you myself included
are back home you're ready to go to
sleep you're winding down for the day
your body's here like physical body is
right here but what i find is your mind
is not here
so where is it it's still for many
people still stuck
at your job you're laying in your bed
but your mind
is with the activity at your work your
mind is still with the argument that you
had earlier in the day
your mind is with a project your mind is
still
in your past how someone hurt you
how someone deceived you the things that
happened to you before
some people are in the future and we're
worried of what are we gonna do next and
our mind isn't here in this present
moment many people are struggling with
shutting off i mean i think many of you
out there are doing an amazing job
trying your best to
make a living
to
improve your relationship with your
families
do a good job with school and work and
everyone is out there putting in the
effort but one of the things that people
struggle with commonly time and time
again is then
they're so invested in the outside world
they're so invested in the doing and it
takes up a lot of your time
so when we do come back home it's hard
for us to cut off one of the tips that i
always give them is again have a cut off
time
when you're out in your daily life do
the best you can give it all you got
but also then when you do come back you
need to retreat you need to recharge and
the way you do that is then pick kind of
a time
pick an activity that helps to remind
you of okay
now we're done
now it's the cool off process and what i
find is simple for our new monks and
maybe for you
is then shower time
because shower time is something that we
do in the evening before we wind down
and as you are
going to the shower and now getting
ready then use that already to tell your
mind that we're shutting off
and when you're in the act of showering
when you have the water on and it's
cleaning your skin
just take a breath
just close your eyes and imagine okay
now we're done for the day
let go
of everything that you experience from
the day
and wash it off
wipe it out and release it
and
let it go
this is the most important part because
we need the rest of our time to recharge
and recoup
so if you can already go into this
activity of saying i'm getting ready to
wind down i'm getting ready to turn off
and what are we turning off and for us
is turning off the thinking part you've
used this the brain part of yourself so
much and it's on
overload and it's very active
it's okay because you needed it but now
when you are back home then turn it off
and now come back to this present moment
and then that way you can
refresh yourself
earlier in that evening just take a
moment to reflect on how your day was
what good did you do today
you know just in this last 24 hours
what good habits did you do
how was your meditation
how did you
give to other people
all the positive things that took effect
as of today also then reflect on the
things that did not go so well
maybe there are specific patterns for
you that keep struggling
with it and today it was challenging and
today you were not that successful and
it's okay but just reflect on that we
don't go to bed just thinking about our
problem ruminating about it
that's not how that works but really is
before we're gonna go to sleep recollect
the merit just thinking of the good
deeds that you're done that you're proud
of
recall this is the most important part
not so much the thinking part but
recalling the feeling
collect the goodness that you did from
this week what good things did you do
did you help your partner and your
spouse did you donate your time and your
resources
what good did you do this month what
good did you do this year what good did
you do this lifetime and collect it
and cover yourself like a blanket
when we have this evening routine it's
kind of a structure and a protection and
a training for your mind to come back
home
leave the past
leave the future and just come back
here
the simple behavior that i do believe
everybody should adopt is to view
ideally sunlight for two to ten minutes
every morning upon waking so when you
get up in the morning
you really want to get bright light into
your eyes because it does two things
first of all it triggers the timed
release of cortisol a healthy
level of cortisol into your system which
acts as a wake up signal and will
promote wakefulness and the ability to
focus throughout the day
it also starts a timer for the onset of
melatonin this sleepyness hormone or the
hormone of darkness as they say
melatonin is inhibited by light
so by viewing light first thing in the
day
you set in motion these two timers one
for wakefulness that starts immediately
and one for sleepiness that starts later
as you approach the evening or night
time and you want to go to sleep that is
a time to start avoiding bright lights
of any color not just blue light
and if possible to place whatever lights
are present in your environment lower in
your visual field so this would be desk
lamps in the evening you really want to
avoid bright light of any kind bright
light exposure of any wavelength between
the hours of about 11 pm and 4 am
cause a serious disruption in the
dopamine system such that in subsequent
days
you have a disruption in a lowering of
mood difficulty in learning there's a
cascade of things that happen in other
words we get punished for light viewing
at the wrong times of the circadian
cycle and we get rewarded for light
viewing at the correct times of the
circadian cycle
you could be dead exhausted and go to
sleep right away but your sleep quality
because your brain still buzzing from
thinking it's daytime and all that stuff
so that's what i always tell people as i
say two hours before you want to go to
bed do everything you can to put
yourself in a mental state to prepare
yourself for sleep you don't get to
decide whether you're a morning type or
an evening type it's hardwired into your
genes we know the genes it's not your
fault if you're an evening type and
you're listening to this and society
which is strongly architected against
your chronotype we we reward and we
favor the morning types um
it is not your fault it's not a choice
many owls think that they have insomnia
they don't they're just not going to bed
at the right time because they get into
bed and it's like a teenager whose
rhythm has also shifted late you tell
them to go to bed because you've got to
wake up for early school start times but
there's nothing they can do because
their circadian rhythm has shifted
forward in time it's the same for owls
so what will happen is that they will
probably stay awake for a little while
then they'll get into deep sleep but
then they have to wake up at an earlier
time and they will lose a lot of rem
sleep rem sleep for emotional well-being
what do owls typically experience
depression low mood anxiety
i don't get enough sleep then i'm quite
grumpy i mean obviously i think most
people that way and and also
like i try to figure out what's the
right amount of sleep i found i could
have dropped below a certain threshold
of sleep and although i'd be awake more
hours and i could sustain it that would
get less done because mental acuity
would be affected so i found generally
the right number for me is around six to
six and a half hours on average per
night
my night routine is very simple complete
the day and leave no tasks that i have
to finish in the morning
then once that's all handled i turn off
all the lights i lock the front door
when i walk into my bedroom the very
first thing that i do
i set my alarm
and then i plug my phone in in my closet
we tend to be sleepy as our temperature
is falling getting lower and we tend to
be more awake or waking
when our temperature is increasing this
is a biological fact it is
right down to our dna and
if we are living our life in a perfect
way where we wake up in the morning
and we view sunlight as it crosses the
horizon
and then by evening we catch a little
sunlight
and then at night we're in complete
darkness
we will be more or less perfectly
matched to the external or ambient light
dark cycle very few of us do that
because of these things that we call
artificial lights and this other thing
that we call life demands we were
designed literally
our cells and the circuits of our body
were constructed to be
awake during the daytime and asleep at
night
you basically want to get as much light
ideally sunlight but as much light into
your eyes during the period of each 24
hour cycle when you want to be awake
when you want to be alert
and you want to get as little light into
your eyes at the times of that 24 hour
cycle when you want to be asleep
or drowsy and falling asleep
every evening before you go to bed
take the time to recollect all the good
things that you've done
all the generosity all the act of
kindness and then
reconnect with that proud feeling